welcome back to cbs warnings for ahmad
aubrey's mother yesterday's verdict in
brunswick georgia came after a 21-month
search for justice involving prayer and
hard work three men were convicted of
killing her son after chasing him down
in brunswick they each faced the
possibility of a life sentence in prison
wanda cooper jones got emotional in the
courtroom after the verdict was read
yesterday it was a day she once thought
would never come she joins us now to
talk about her son and his legacy good
morning and thank you so much for being
with us
hey good morning thank you for having me
thank you
at ahmad's funeral you made a promise to
him that you would get justice no matter
how hard the journey would be
here we are 17 months later and you
fulfilled that promise what was your
verdict yeah what was your reaction to
the verdict
i was very very excited
it was like a dream come true
yesterday was really a big victory for
my family and i
so much has been said about the video do
you think that this verdict would have
been possible without it the trial even
i don't think without that video we
wouldn't have any arrests nevertheless a
trial
what went into you preparing the world
really step by step that hard work
keeping ahmad's name face and story in
the public eye how did you do it
i thought it was very important to keep
in mind's name
i'm alive simply because we went 74 days
without an arrest i mean we went like
two weeks without any anybody knowing
about the actual what happened to him on
that sunday afternoon
so from that point on i knew that we had
to keep it in the light of things um to
get some justice for some justice for
mine
miss cooper jones it's vlad uh sitting
in that courtroom day in day out
watching all of this play out which
might not have even happened if you had
not promised ahmad
at his funeral if the world hadn't seen
that video what were you thinking about
the justice system as you sat there
as i stopped there i
often thought the justice system was i
was very unfair
but i also reminded myself that these
are the things that i miss lewis mother
to to to make sure that we get justice
for a mom
that should have been done back in 2020.
the reverend al sharpton even referenced
the makeup of the jury that there were
11 whites on this jury and only one
person of color
that saw and said that black lives
matter
that statement and with this verdict
what do you hope it has as far as an
impact on on the greater country on the
world out there
i hope the guilty verdict in a mom's
case would will give the families that
have gotten no justice at this point
some sense of encouragement that if you
keep pushing you keep fighting that
justice will prevail
you had to sit through some pretty
intense testimony some of which was was
was disparaging to the memory of your
son i know so many people are talking
about the toenail
moment in the courtroom
how did you stay strong through that and
what was your what was your reaction to
that
when i heard the remark about this long
dirty toenails i immediately left the
courtroom because i felt like that was
very disrespectful
to not only to to ahmad but to his
family that was sitting there watching
um
then i said to myself that she she said
that only because she was trying to
demand
a mind and but at the same time ahmad
was killed while he was jogging
regardless of how long his toenails were
and he didn't deserve that at all
so what would you say to the three men
responsible for your son's death if you
could talk to them
that we finally got justice for a mind
i'm so sorry that your back decisions
made all of my family suffer to this
extreme
but it was your decisions that god was
here
you know you mentioned the suffering
your family does not get ahmad back
obviously even with this verdict but you
can keep his legacy alive how do you
hope people will think of ahmad going
forward when they hear his name
i would like people to think vermont's
name is change
because lamar has impacted
changes in georgia's already with the
citizens of rest law
he also was the reason why they repel
they implemented this the hate crime law
here in georgia so i'm hoping that when
they hear the name of my aubry it will
it will prompt them to think about
change
we know it's a holiday and we certainly
wish you and your family the best on
this holiday wanda cooper jones thank
you for the time
okay thank you ma'am